I really hate that so many predictions have
come true this week because of what it means
about the state of our democracy.
Before there was any victory to claim this
week, Donald Trump said at two a.m. on Friday.
On Tuesday night, early Wednesday morning
that he won the election.
Then he started with the claims that it was
rigged about votes being found, all claims
which were flagged by Twitter as potentially
misleading about an election.
And now Donald Trump is starting with lawsuits.
The vote count resumed in Pennsylvania yesterday.
And as this was happening, Donald Trump's
personal lawyer, Rudy Giuliani, and Donald
Trump's one of Donald Trump's sons, Eric Trump,
went to Philadelphia to announce major action
to stop the terrible cheating and vote counting
that was going on at the time.
It is not lost on me that in some cases Donald
Trump was saying we must stop counting votes
in other places.
Donald Trump was saying we must continue counting
votes and so were his supporters and will
get to some of that video.
But first, Rudy Giuliani's explanation is
complete and total incoherence, saying that
he will file two lawsuits and a federal lawsuit
and maybe a national lawsuit.
I can't even get through this with a straight
face.
Take a look at this and say that insanity.
And I challenge you to tell me what on earth
is Rudy talking about?
A hundred thousand fraudulent, meaningless
paper ballots that no one gets to observe.
So we are going to continue the lawsuit here.
We're going to bring a second one and then
we're going to bring a federal lawsuit and
we're going to take a very good look at whether
we bring this nationally.
We certainly are going to bring it here.
And in Wisconsin, quite possibly, we'll do
a national lawsuit and really expose the corruption
of the Democrat Party.
But this is beyond anything I've ever seen
before.
This comes when you think you have so much
power and you own the media that you can do
anything you want.
Well, sorry, we're going to fight for the
people.
We're going to vindicate their right.
And the ultimate result is President Trump
has won Pennsylvania.
He's going to vindicate people.
He's filing for lawsuits.
This is maybe Rudy Giuliani's most humiliating
moment.
And I've seen the Borat scene for people to
be to understand.
I'm including that as well.
It's a deranged person making no sense or
Trump put him up to it and he feels like he
can't say no.
That's the only other explanation I can imagine.
So in an attempt to tell you what is actually
going on.
And just as a reminder, many times people
say they are filing a lawsuit and they don't.
I'm just saying when Rudy says on a whim,
I'm filing two to four lawsuits, let's verify
that the lawsuits have actually been filed.
But the claim is that Trump's campaign is
filing lawsuits to stop the counting of ballots
in Michigan and Pennsylvania as they are demanding
increased access to observe the tallying process
at a bunch of locations in these key states.
Trump and the Georgia Republican Party have
also filed a lawsuit in Georgia.
We don't know why.
We don't know for what.
We don't yet know exactly who they are suing.
Their at least as of the time that we went
to record today.
Maybe by now we know what that lawsuit is
about.
The Trump campaign also said that the lawsuit
demands that the Michigan lawsuit or the Pennsylvania
one or both demands that they want to review
ballots which were opened and counted without
them having meaningful access.
And, of course, what
that means, we don't know now the sort of
funny thing or perverted thing, depending
on your perspective, is when Trump announced
that they were doing this, he was losing Michigan
and ultimately Michigan was straight up called
for Biden.
So my instinct, you might say, why would you
stop counting when you're losing, like in
Michigan?
In Pennsylvania, he wants to stop counting
while he's winning.
As of the time of that announcement, my thought
is the stop.
The count is sort of an intermediate measure
meant to give them more time to come up with
something else, count the vote, stop the count
temporarily, and then figure out what's the
next claim that you're going to make.
But there was actually an even better moment
during this, and we caught it live during
my stream yesterday.
And I want to get to that nex